le débat sur le mariage homosexuel
reprend de la vigueur au moment où une
mission parlementaire sur la famille et
les droits de l'enfant s'apprête à
rendre ses conclusions et c'est dans ce
contexte que 50 maires de villes grandes
et moyennes ont décidé de prendre
ouvertement position contre le mariage
gay leur initiative s'ajoute à une liste
d'élus essentiellement de la majorité
qui ont déjà pris position sur internet
jean-françois fierais et silvano bas ils
se sont dits oui voilà qui va rassurer
plus d'un
ou plutôt 12000 12000 maires de france
farouche défenseur d'une union
traditionnelle entre un homme et une
femme tous ont signé sur le site
internet de leur collectif cet appel
pour l'enfance il désapprouve tout
projet d'instauration d'un mariage entre
personnes du même sexe et conteste
l'implication du maire dans une
célébration de ce type
la liste est anonyme seuls 50 élus la
plupart de droite
quelques-uns de gauche ont révélé leur
identité certains souhaitaient donc
qu'il y ait le pacte pour que de manier
le mariage des homosexuels pour qu'après
demain il y ait la possibilité d'adopter
des enfants par les homosexuels et nous
nous considérons que la famille ne peut
s'épanouir que dans un cadre
hétérosexuels dans le sens où il faut
pour les enfants des repères un père une
mère pour qu'ils puissent se construire
au maine la crainte du collectif
l'homoparentalité
et pourtant même à droite la question
divise nadine morano ump y est depuis
longtemps favorable mais elle le sait la
partie n'est pas gagnée
c'est direct c'est aussi somme toute
normal que nous n'ayons pas tous les
mêmes positions on en débat on en
discute on voit jusqu'à quelles
évolutions il faut aller et c'est comme
ça qu'un parti un grand parti politique
doit travailler
éléments de réponse jeudi prochain avec
la publication d'un rapport sur la
famille probable recommandations de
nouveaux droits pour les couples
homosexuels
toujours dans le cadre du pacs le
mariage gay lui est déjà autorisé aux
pays bas en belgique en espagne et
depuis peu en grande bretagne le débat
sera pas nos portes